well I think management of the skills
and how you do think leadership is
really the ability to empower people to
align people around a common mission and
values to set standards of what you want
to be and what you want an organization
to become and then to empower other
people to step up and lead it's not
about leaders and followers like we used
to think a leaders are not people to be
able to follow them they're people
inspire others to lead and leadership is
service it's about serving whether your
customers or your students if you want
in an academic sense certainly the
employees will work with you and people
the your owners but I think it's really
more about service and we've had too
many leaders that saw themselves more as
takers
than givers and I think we need leaders
who are givers and that's the influence
I'm trying to have for my new book
TrueNorth interviewed 125 leaders who
are authentic leaders and I think you
can't be a good leader unless you can be
the authentic person you were meant to
be and too much of our leadership
development in the 70s and 80s and even
90s was focused on trying to make you
into a standard leader to emulate other
great leaders or to be a charismatic
leader or to fit a certain set of traits
and characteristics and what we learned
and what I've learned is leadership is
not about any of those things it's about
being who you are and having integrity
and everything you do and empowering
other people around a common belief set
and if you can do that you can lead and
I think it doesn't matter how old you
are or how young you are you can become
that leader and that's the message I've
been trying to communicate to people
I don't think you really do teach
leadership I think you can learn
leadership in my classrooms at Harvard
Business School for instance we believe
not knowledge transfer as in from the
professor to the student but more
knowledge exchange where people are
sharing their leadership experiences
studying what other leaders did saying
what would I do if I were in that
situation and exchanging ideas about
leadership and particularly where they
had failed or where there are faced
crises or where they face difficult
times which we call crucibles that's
where the real learning comes from and
it's the magic of the classroom the
dialogue that I I find so so precious
and such a great learning opportunity
well I think it should be but it
certainly hasn't been I think all too
often business leaders have been in
there to take as much as they could get
for themselves or for their organization
rather than recognizing the greater good
and that the only reason for business
existing in our society is if it makes a
contribution to the societal good we
have no other basis for existing and I
was on the board of a French company
once when the socialist government of
Francois Mitterrand came in and
immediately nationalized the company
which was bull the computer company of
which I was on which I was serving on
the board and because in that in the
French sense companies had no right to
exist and we saw here in the United
States
sarbanes-oxley came in it's to limit the
powers of business leaders because they
took advantage of the system and so I
think business has a deep responsibility
to realize how is it contributing
Society at Medtronic we were very
cognizant of the fact that we were
storing seven or eight million people
every year to full life at health and if
we produced a low quality product we had
failed in what we were doing but if we
did that well we made a great
contribution to human life and I think
each organization in its own way not
maybe not saving lives but contributes
to society if they do it well and if
they don't they'll go out of business
they won't exist anymore
you know honestly I'm very optimistic
about the current generation what I call
the post Enron CEOs people like Jeff
Immelt at General Electric and Andrea
Jung at Avon products animal kehe at
Xerox we have some great leaders coming
up Sam Palmisano at IBM AG Lafley at
Procter & Gamble and many many leaders
of smaller companies like the leaders at
Google and and a lot of the startup
companies and Howard Schultz at
Starbucks there's just a great new
generation of leaders you know why
because they realize how so many and our
generation did it wrong and you can
almost characterize my generation is the
unilateralis leader so we're gonna do it
our way
and the new generation realized we have
to be collaborative leaders we have to
collaborate within and we also have to
collaborate with other institutions
either other businesses governments or
nonprofit organizations so instead of
fighting against those organizations the
wise organizations are now finding ways
to bond with them to accomplish greater
societal needs you know having studied
leaders most of my life and having
formally done it through this research I
I think it's really not a question of
other leaders are made or born I think
because we're all born with the gifts of
leadership but each of us is unique
there's no standard set but we have to
develop those gifts just if like you're
a great musician and you want to want to
be great musician you want to go to
Carnegie Hall you'd practice you're
you're using your gifts every day same
with great athletes I think it's no
different with leaders leaders have to
develop themselves as leaders and our
study of leaders every single leader who
has failed that I've studied failed to
lead themselves and so if we can help
people develop themselves to leadership
from within rather than just leadership
from without they can become great
leaders but they to using gifts they
have if they try to emulate someone
else's gifts they will fail without
question
you know for too long we've been
studying what are the characteristics
and traits the great leadership sand I
could reel off a list of ten or twenty
five traits and characteristics but
every great leader that I could name
would miss some of those traits and
there may be people have all those
traits are not great leadership so I in
my and what I learned from 125 years I
interviewed and from my own personal
experience of working with literally
hundreds of leaders
it's not about traits or characteristics
it's about your life story and it's
about fidelity to your life's or who you
are if you have certain tapes running
through your head about saying Who am I
in this Who am I in this world where in
my passion to what I want to do and out
of that comes your capacity for
leadership and we've just seen time
after time leaders be inspired by their
own stories by their own difficult by
their own crucibles Oprah Winfrey talks
about the abuse she encountered as a
young girl but it was until she was 36
that she was able to frame and see this
as that gave her inspiration to say you
know what my show is all about is
empowering people to take responsibility
for their lives Howard Schultz talks
about wanting to create a company in
Starbucks that his father never had a
chance to work at that his father to be
proud to work at and that's why he gave
health care to all his workers because
they want to be a great place to work
and through that create a relationship
between the customers and the employees
and so through their life stories we
found almost every leader found their
inspiration to lead that's what
empowered them to become great leader